next here's what's next the
commanderin-chief Joe Biden needs to
wake up and do something about a broken
border it's his job above all others to
secure the
nation here's what we learned this week
in
judiciary the secretary I mean excuse me
the director of the FBI said when asked
about blinking lights threats I see
blinking lights everywhere I turn since
October the seventh now people need to
understand that what happened to Israel
affects you too now we've all chosen
Republicans and Democrats to support
Israel because we should we need to
Hamas would kill all of us if they could
we need to be behind our friends in
Israel what does that mean for us the
Threat Level has gone to a whole other
level since October the 7th post October
the 7th a vertual roads gallery of
terrorist organizations are calling for
attacks against uses so what does that
mean the people who want to destroy
Israel are trying to pay us back for
helping Israel President Biden you don't
need to negotiate with any of us you
have the ability as president to stop
this problem now if you choose to use
the law that is available to you why is
the border so broken because the policy
choices of President Biden are not
working
next I've ever seen a time when all the
threats or so many of the threats are
all elevated at exactly the same time
next this was December the
6th fighting age males lined up as far
as you can
see bottom line is we're urging the
president to get involved and fix this
problem Senator Murphy's a fine fellow
but it's never going to happen as long
as Senator Schumer is in charge of these
negotiations we're going to have to get
the president of the United States
involved he owes it to the American
people to fix a broken border and when I
say broken what do I mean I mean really
broken in the last four days we've had
40,000 illegal Crossings two days ago
was the highest on record we're
averaging for the last seven days 9400
people we're on track to 3.6 million
this year Alone 6 million up to date uh
when since he's been president larger
than 21 states the threat levels that
are all-time high the uh illegal
Crossings into our country in an
all-time high and my Democratic
colleagues are saying what do we get to
secure the Border you get a safer
country you're not going to get
legalization of illegal immigrants in
this de this is about securing our
border so we can then help our allies
I'm going to turn it over to my
colleagues but this I cannot and I will
not do I will not go back to South
Carolina and try to explain why I helped
Ukraine Taiwan and Israel and did
nothing to secure our own border I will
help all of our allies but we got to
help ourselves first again you don't
need to change the law for this to stop
you need the president to use the tools
available and change his policies
President Biden had a goal to prove to
the American people he was not Donald
Trump when it came the immigration and
Border policy you have exceeded Beyond
Your Wildest
imagination how many Americans would
love to have the
Border secured like President Trump was
able to do it you can do it you have to
want to do it you have to choose to do
it so these negotiations need to change
the president of the United States
should be involved he is responsible for
this situation more than any member of
the House and the Senate he is the
commanderin-chief when it comes to
securing our border our
commander-in-chief Joe Biden is awal
Senator
BR like Senator Graham my constituents
ask when are you going to do something
about the Border as Senator Graham said
it's already against the law to enter
our country without our
permission but we pass those laws and
they've been on the books for a long
period of time in turn the
president is the enforcer of the laws
and he has decided not to enforce these
laws Because he believes in an open
border and this is secure has brought
about a national security problem when
you read regularly about
169 Milli 169 people on the uh Terror
watch list that have entered the country
and those are the ones we know about
because we
they're on
record and what I don't get about this
whole thing is if you're on the Terrace
watch list you never get on an airplane
to come into the United
States so how can you fly to Mexico or
however you want to get to Mexico be on
the Terrace watch list and get into this
country without being denied the same
way you would be if you want to get on
an
airplane so we have to do something
about this it's up to the Presidents to
do it but we need some policy changes
that that's what this debate is all
about I'm really glad that all the
people up here with me and people that
aren't up here with me one week after
October 7th we sent a letter to the
president of the United States warning
him about the fact that uh there could
be uh because of what happened in Israel
terrorist attacks was in the United
States I don't know whether he took that
very seriously or not but we know that
we expected this to happen from the
people that are on the terrorist watch
list we must secure the Border it's one
of the top three things that the voters
of this country are interested in it's
common sense it's the law the president
of the United States just like we have
have taken an oath to uphold the
Constitution and the president isn't
doing that we're going to do this by
thanks Lindsay thanks your leadership
what yesterday's vote um should have
made clear is that Republicans are dead
serious about solving Biden's border
crisis as part of the National Security
part and parcel of the National Security
uh debate that we're having on the floor
of the Senate right now and as Lindsay
pointed out this was a policy choice
this Administration made a Clear Choice
when they took office to completely
abandon and do away with the policies of
the previous administration that were
working at our Southern border so much
so now that you have even you know
people like J Johnson who was the
homeland security department secretary
under President Obama said at the time
that a thousand people a day would
overwhelm the system and then he
couldn't even imagine what 4,000 a day
look like well now we're triple that 10
to thou 12,000 people a day these last
few days are just absolutely
overwhelming our system and this is a
huge National Security uh crisis for our
country which uh Republicans are as I
said dead set on solving and we have put
forward uh proposals that are meaningful
and real and serious and at getting at
our border crisis so far Democrats have
resisted uh this President and Democrats
here in the Senate have to get serious
about fixing this or U not only are we
going to continue to face a major crisis
a national security crisis at our
Southern border but we're not going to
be able to deal with the other National
Security threats that we face around the
world the lights are blinking
red that's what Chris Ray said the
lights are blinking everywhere I turn if
that isn't a warning I don't know what
is you got people every day some of whom
are on the terrorist watch list this
problem has to be solved it's got to be
solved now and the Democrats need to get
serious about working with us to make
that
happen well it looks like we've finally
gotten uh President Biden's
attention 7 million migrants across our
borders since he became
president 1.7 million gotway people
invading law enforcement up to who knows
what we know how many people were
stopped on the terrorist watch list at
border control intercepted but we have
no idea of the number of people who are
on that watch list who are among those
1.7 million Goda
aways and there's another number
108,000 that's the number of Americans
who died of drug overdoses including
fentanyl poisoning last year alone
fentanyl from Mexico the precursors come
from China and they're made to look like
something relatively innocuous and I've
been to six different high schools where
parents are daming having lost their
child to fanol poison this is the number
one cause of death for Americans between
the age of 18 and
45 another number I'll mention is
300,000 that's the number of
unaccompanied children who have beened
with in the interior of the United
States that the Administration has lost
track of they can't tell you whether
these children are going to school
whether they're being sex trafficed
whether they're being forced into labor
involuntary servitude they don't know
and obviously they don't
care so those numbers I mentioned to you
President Biden has been on moved to
work with us to try to come up with a
solution but now we found something that
uh provides us the opportunity to force
the administration to do something that
they've been unwilling to do until this
point and we intend to do everything we
can to make sure that these policies are
put in place to stem the flow of illegal
immigration in our country along with
other all the
other problems that go along with it
legal immigration has been one of the
greatest blessings that this country has
ever experienced legal immigration but
president bid outsourc our immigration
policy to the cartels who smuggle people
by the by the head for thousands of
dollars and the drug cartels that took
the lives of 108,000 Americans last year
alone our nation faces several grave
threats we have Iran trying to kill
American troops or blow up our ships
every day in the Middle East radical
isic Terror groups like alqaeda or Isis
Moss Hezbollah threaten our
people we're rising and Bolden and
aggressive Russia and China but there is
no more urgent threat to this nation
than our wide open Southern
border you've heard these numbers
they're astonishing 10 to 12, people a
day crossing our border with no right to
be here just put that in perspective
over 3.6 million people a year it'll
probably be more than that the num
continue to increase that is more than
the entire population of the state of
Arkansas for that matter it's more than
the entire population of state of
Arkansas by Halloween you can get a
Vermont throw in for Thanksgiving and
Christmas as well and it's not just the
fact that that puts strain on jobs and
wages for American workers or schools
and Hospital systems and housing but
hundreds and hundreds of those people
are on the terror watch list or they
so-called persons of concern that could
be infiltrating our company our to
commit Mass casually Terror attacks
against our people and they are here not
by accident but because of Joe Biden's
specific policy choices our border was
closed the day Joe Biden took office now
we have 12,000 illegal migrants Crossing
every day because he abuses our Asylum
laws because he extends parole to vast
groups of people as opposed to a case by
case basis even the day-to-day tactical
challenges he won't let the border
patrol defend themselves or defend what
stretches of law there are from attack
and from destruction he turns a blind
eye when the cartels are trafficking
people across our border or setting up
de facto travel agencies in the old
world that's why not just Republicans
and Congress but the American people say
Joe Biden has done a terrible job on our
border and they are tired of it and
demanding change now Senator Graham said
Joe Biden could change tomorrow he could
Implement policies tomorrow that would
not just substantially reduce but almost
entirely stop the flow of illegal
migrants to include potential terrorists
across our border he has shown no
willingness to do that because he has
shown no willingness to show up to stand
up to the radical left of his party and
if he is not willing to do that then we
will have to force him to do that the
Democrats and the Senate have not yet
come to grips that
that they are going to have to Grant
significant concessions On the Border
pass the president
supplemental Aid package and certainly
the House of Representatives will
command that and until they accept that
reality the legislation will
pass Senator Graham thank you for
posting this thank you for continuing to
bring attention to this and thank you to
all the gentlemen behind me who continue
to work diligently to actually secure
our border that's what the American
people deserve but unfortunately Joe
Biden refuses to give that to them you
know when we look at this emergency
supplemental when we look at this
National Security Supplemental when we
look at what Joe Biden sent us he put
money for the Border in there but do you
know what that was it was stuff that
continues to facilitate the Mass
migration that we see across our border
it was yet more of a magnet to draw more
and more people here now I want to tell
you who benefits from that because we
have both a national security and a
humanitarian crisis on our border the
liberal media has decided to turn a
blind eye to the fact that women are
being raped on our border that children
are being recycled on our border that we
have laws that allow that to happen and
actually that that's what some of these
children are going
through guys when are you going to
actually call it like it is and not like
the liberal left wants you to the
reality is these policies are
inhumane you look at the national
security threat of this y we've gone
through a week where we had 10,000 come
over the Border 10,000 come over the
Border 12 ,000 an all-time high and to
what Senator th said secretary J Johnson
under President Obama said 1,000 a day
would be a crisis we're hitting
12 we must secure our border for the
Safety and Security of the American
people I don't want to sit across from
another mama who lost their child to
fentol poisoning you know I I don't want
to look out and and see the travesty
that occurs as a result of this and at
the end of the day when we're putting
policies in place to ensure that we have
National Security the first among all of
these must be the border and youall need
to wake up because Senator Graham asked
the questions yesterday he asked
director Ray about this he said I've
never seen a time this is the response
do director Ray I've never seen a time
where all the threats or so many of the
threats are all elevated at exactly the
same time he followed up with I see
blinking lights everywhere I turn he set
a heighten threat environment from
foreign terrorist organizations and
obviously the ability to export exploit
points of Entry including our Southwest
border Senate Democrats and President
Joe
Biden are putting the American people
last we need to make sure we create
deterrence we need to make sure we that
we create safety and we must do more for
the people here at home they deserve it
and that is exactly what we are going to
continue to fight
for actually I want to start by thanking
Senator James Langford who you all know
is on point for negotiating uh with our
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle for the work he's doing um and my
colleagues here who are also having disc
is trying to get to a good outcome also
want to thank border patrol and Customs
agents whose morale is at an alltime low
they know that they're overrun they're
dreading going to work every day because
they know they're not going to succeed
at their mission this President could
end this crisis right now without a
single bill being passed we know he's
not going to do that but we know it can
be done because Trump did this President
also knows that the likely nominee for
the Republican party and many people
think the lik president to be sworn in
next January is Donald J Trump he said
on his first day he was going to shut
down the border and I think he means it
and I hope that he would but you know
who's listening to that right now it's
the cartels and if you don't think that
they're going to ramp up their
advertising and try to double the flows
that are already four times the Trump
eror flows then you're crazy and that's
exactly why president Trump's willing to
go further because he knows he's already
got a political problem and it's going
to get a lot worse but let's not talk
about politics where he's already losing
let's talk about the threat I'll leave
you with this and I really haven't seen
much attention paid to this but the last
time I went to the border at about 1:00
a. I stood on the on the ril Grande
river right uh maybe about five or six
feet shot of a fluorescent
arrow with coyotes across the river
saying we're coming now what they meant
by that is they're going to send about
50 people over so border patrol will be
engaged so that they can bring fenel or
illicit materials AC the Border because
we simply don't have enough border
agents on patrol they said we are coming
now 100 one and a half million people
have crossed the border over the last
two years that are so-called known Goda
ways we know they came here people don't
go back to Mexico once they cross the
real Grande River they do everything
they can but these people are paying a
premium and going through sectors of the
border that they're doing everything
they can to avoid border patrol back to
that fluorescent era if they didn't have
a bad record if they weren't somebody
who was a threat to the Homeland why on
Earth would they pay money to go through
some of the most dangerous sections of
the border to evade
apprehension why would they do that
unless they've got a bad history unless
they've got a malign purpose one and a
half million people let's assume only
let's assume only 10% do that's
150,000 people ladies and gentlemen so I
care about Ukraine Homeland Security I
care about Israel's Homeland Security
but it would be IM moral for me to put
those to a head of what I think is a
clear and present threat to our homeland
security seven senators in 21 minutes
that's
question got two one on policy and then
one sort of about the meeting this week
uh on policy what exactly do you want on
Asylum and Parole and then on the
meeting what did you say to General
Brown did you ask about where he was
born and and tell us the background why
why you did that if you that was
I asked him when's the last time You'
been to the border and he said I was
born in Texas I didn't think that was a
good response you know I like General
Brown you know he's a great guy got
nothing against General Brown I was
frustrated because nobody up there knew
anything about the border so when you
when I said when's the last time you get
went to the Border you tell me you're
born in Texas that's not answering my
question so I like General Brown he's a
great guy but they didn't have one
person there to talk about the Border
everything was about Ukraine everybody
behind me will day to Ukraine if we can
get the border right and then Asylum and
parole what would you like uh number one
start with things that we know work if
you're past the credible fear standard
your hearing is on average what three or
four years four stay outside the United
States once you let people loose into
the country it gets back all over the
world once you get to America you never
leave the first thing you need to do to
stop the flow or slow it down is make
sure that people waiting for the solum
hearing are not released into the
country because that incentivizes people
to come because once they get released
the belief is you're never going to go
back stop paroling people on mass
240,000 people were given blanket parole
under a statute that requires an
individual analysis based on substantial
benefit to the country or undue unusual
humanitarian need quit abusing the law
he could do both of those things without
one one bill being passed has been said
he's chosen to let people loose in the
country he's chosen to abuse the parole
law and his choice has led to a broken
border with elevated terrorist threats
Joe Biden has been asleep at the wheel
when it comes to the Border you need to
wake up Mr President before we get hit
Senator Murphy was asked downstairs if
he thought the record 12,000 encounters
at the border on Tuesday was a problem
and whether he shares your desire to
lower the number of encounters he says
what the problem is is that there aren
enough resources to process those
encounters so these negotiations should
end because he doesn't understand it's
hard to fix a problem if you don't
understand what it's all about if you
think 12,000 people are coming here
because we're under resourced that's
insane they're coming here because they
believe once they get here they never
leave under Biden once you show up at
the border you're going to stay here
forever catch and release is why they're
coming Chris it's not about resources
the apology choices of allowing
everybody apply for Asylum to stay in
the country to wait for a hearing four
years from now has led to a a a surge at
the border parole is being abused it is
about policy choices not about resources
well to be fair the president's
supplemental
request the president's supplemental
request was funding to address the
symptoms the symptoms are a New York
mayor saying it's out of control Chicago
is saying they've had too many people
sleeping in tents in cold conditions he
was there to actually request money to
address the symptom we're here to fix
the
problem and just to follow up it would
is daaka amnesty in exchange for policy
nothing nothing to incentivize more
illegal IM I can't think of a worse idea
than to give people legal
status right now legalizing people
incentivize more people to come maybe
I'll be in the next wave of DACA no
legalization
secure the border to get money for
Ukraine to get money for Israel and to
help Taiwan secure the border before we
get attacked secure the border before
the next terrorist attack happens the
SEC uh the director of the FBI said
since October the 7th a Road's gallery
of terrorist groups are urging their
members and people who are sympathetic
their calls to attack America what do
you get you get a safer country Senator
um two questions I to guys on the
timeline do you think the deal is
possible before the end of the year and
then secondarily can you speak to just
kind of the fundamental disagreement
seems like obviously you guys are very
much about deterrence you don't you want
to send a different message to people
that they don't shouldn't come here that
you're not welcome to be released in
this country but Democrats fundamentally
don't want to send that message they
don't want to tell migrants they're not
welcome here they don't want to say you
have to stay in these home countries and
wait years agree with you so how do you
get past that fundamental IDE they got
to change their messaging or we're not
going to survive of this nation here's
what I tell my Democratic colleagues you
want to please people that literally
want the border to stay open in an
unlimited fashion 76% of Americans would
like to see the Border
secured it's like pulling teeth talking
to these guys would I get how can I sell
this to my caucus here's what you need
to sell to your caucus on your watch on
the Biden Administration is watch the
largest amount of legal Crossing is
occurring da
we're on track that 10 million illegal
immigrants in the first in four years of
the Biden Administration the threats to
the country at all time high what do you
get you get a secure Nation if you work
with us on the timeline can you talk
about I mean if you think that these
talks are failing if you think the talks
are failing is there any practical
ability for you to pass something by the
end of the year I don't think the talks
are failing um there are conversations
going on right now and I'm hopeful are
going to produce a result but that
happens only if the Democrats get
serious and as has been pointed out I
mean the the Democrat mayor of New York
Eric Adams is in town today meeting with
Chuck Schumer and um talking about what
I'm sure he's been sharing publicly and
that is that this crisis is creating
huge problems for him in New York having
to cut education funding having to close
libraries having to freeze hiring police
force I mean these this this has real
quences not just for Border communities
but for communities all across this
country so it's got to be dealt with
it's got to be fixed and I think the
vote yesterday if nothing else sent a
loud clear message to the Democrats that
that's the case now the White House is
going to have to engage um particularly
if Senate Democrats are unwilling to to
to do what we're suggesting to be done
but this isn't a money issue you can't
throw money out these are these are this
requires changes in policy that change
the signals sending the people who are
coming across the border illegally and
the magnets that are out there that keep
pulling them um and and that's what
Senator lford and and others are trying
to accomplish one last question uh
Senator you mentioned that you wanted
the president to get involved would you
consider policy changes through
executive action instead of the
legislative changes well number one
that's a really good question Mr
President you may not know it but you
could actually fix this without any of
us doing anything you could go back to
the policy of making people wait outside
the country for their hearing which is
four years away and here's what I know
Works you're not going to pay 10,000 or
$50,000 to get to the United States to
remain in Mexico for four or five years
that's why people sto so parole tell
your secretary of uh uh Homeland
Security stop paring people on a mass
basis if you did those two things it
would go down dramatically now about
policy fixes we need statutory changes
to make it permanent that the president
of the United States has all the power
he needs to dramatically reduce the flow
to make it lasting Beyond his
administration we need a statute and
here's what he needs to understand if
you don't use your executive tools or
work with us for statutory solution none
of us who are supportive of Ukraine
Israel and Taiwan can vote on a
supplemental because you're making us
pick countries abroad over our own
Homeland Security and I'll end where I
started I've never been more worried
about a terrorist attack on our nation
than I am right now it's just not me
saying it it's all the people in the
intelligence Community Mr President you
are the commanderin-chief you have a
house a playing and a bunch of people
working toward you you're in charge of
the intelligence Community you're in
charge of our nation's National Defense
Mr President your own people are telling
you America is exposed
and I feel like I'm in episode of
24 the clock is kicking can we get there
in time people tell me they're probably
already here you're probably right some
but after October the 7th the number of
people who want to punish us for helping
Israel is through the roof every day
that Israel has to fight for survival
and we have a broken border it's a
dangerous day for America thank
you
hey like or
is I was wondering
elseu
you can
go think I'm
get
yep thank you you bet thank
got this door
here
right
for